as a k-12 educator I often get questions
from parents about how they can foster
their child's composition instruction at
home here's a couple of suggestions to
keep in mind that you can do
first off read have your students read
as much as possible the more that they
read the more they're exposed to
vocabulary and sentence structures that
they might not otherwise have been
exposed to so you want to encourage that
facet of reading as much as possible it
will pay large dividends and their
ability to write later on secondly
formalize your speech if you don't want
your students to write using sentence
fragments or using split infinitives
then be intentional about the way that
you talk to them students mimic the
source of communication that they hear
and read around them if you want that to
play out in the students own writing
make sure that that's a sort of
communication that they hear from you as
well thirdly get them talking about
things ask them about the sorts of
things which they're reading about or
the sorts of things that they're
learning about their other subjects this
is the opportunity for your students to
tell you about the things that they've
learned probe more deeply with questions
ask them why and ask them how they know
those particular things the more that
your students have the experience of
articulating their thoughts the more
that would communicate to their written
composition as well
fourth give them opportunities to write
does give you something as simple as a
letter to a family member or a grocery
list but give your student the
opportunity to actually write and to
write with you the more they have this
opportunity the less daunting it will
seem when they're sitting down to the
written composition of their own that
they need to compose and finally give
them a place in the home that they're
able to write have some portion of the
home be well-stocked with pencils and
papers and take this opportunity to
write with your students as well if you
have a daily practice where you journal
this could be a great opportunity to set
your child next to you and to have them
see you as you are writing each and
every day the more that you put these
sorts of practices into place the less
daunting of a task composition can be
and the more your student can thrive as
a writer
you